i wanted to ask you about something from
a fan perspective i
kind of
you know you as a musician use an online
personality
it seems like you have all these
identities and you play with them um
one of the cool things about the
internet it seems like you can play with
identities so as we move into the
digital world more and more maybe even
in the in the so-called metaverse i mean
i love the metaverse and i love the idea
but like
the way this has all played out
didn't
didn't go well and people are mad about
it and i think i i think we need to like
i think that's temporary i think it's
temporary just like you know how all the
celebrities got together and sang the
song imagined by jeff lennon and
everyone started hating the song imagine
i'm hoping that's temporary because it's
a damn good song
yeah so i think it's just temporary like
when you once you actually have virtual
worlds whatever they're called metaverse
or otherwise is becomes i don't know we
do have virtual worlds like video games
elden ring have you played all right i'm
really afraid of playing that game
literally it looks way too fun it would
look it looks i would want to go there
and stay there forever it's
yeah so fun it's so good it's so nice
um
oh man yeah so that that's th yeah
that's the metaverse that's the
metaverse but you're not really it's how
immersive is it
in the sense that
um does the three dimension like virtual
reality integration necessary can we
really just take up close our eyes and
kind of plug in
in the 2d screen
and become that other being for time and
really enjoy that journey that we take
and we almost become that you're no
longer see i'm no longer lex you're that
creature whatever whatever the hell it
is in that game yeah that is that i mean
that's why i love those video games it's
it's
i really do become those people
for a time but like it seems like with
the idea of the metaverse the idea of
the digital space with even on twitter
you get a chance to be somebody for
prolonged periods of time like across a
lifespan you know you have a twitter
account for
years for decades and you're that person
i don't know if that's a good thing i
feel very
tormented by it by twitter specifically
by social media representation of you
the i feel like the public perception of
me has gotten so distorted
uh that
i find it kind of disturbing it's one of
the things that's disincentivizing me
from like wanting to keep making art
because i'm just like
i've completely lost control of the
narrative and the narrative is
some of it is my own stupidity but a lot
like some of it has just been like
hijacked by
forces far beyond my control yeah you
know i kind of got in over my head in
things like i'm just a random indie
musician but i just got like dragged
into like
geopolitical matters and like like
financial like the stock market and [ __ ]
and so it's just like it's just there
are very powerful people who have who
have at various points in time had very
vested interest in
making me seem insane and i can't
[ __ ] fight that and i i just like
you know
people really want their celebrity
figures to like
be consistent and stay the same and like
people have a lot of like emotional
investment in certain things and like
first of all i like i
i'm like artificially more famous than i
should be
isn't everybody who's famous
artificially famous
no but like like i should be like like a
weird niche indie thing and i'm i make
pretty challenging i do i do challenging
weird [ __ ] [ __ ] a lot and i
accidentally by proxy got
like
foisted into sort of like weird
celebrity culture but like
i cannot be media trained they have put
me through so many hours of media
training i would love to
i'd love to see bf fly in that wall i
can't do i like well and i do i try so
hard and i like learn this thing oh and
i like got it and i'm like i got it i
got it i got it but i just can't stop
saying
like my mouth just says things i i like
and it's just like and i just do i just
do things i just do crazy i'm gonna like
i'm i just i need to do crazy things and
it's just i should not be
it's too
jarring
for people and
uh and the contradictory stuff and and
then all the
by association
like
you know it's like
i'm in a very weird position and my
public image
the the avatar of me
is now this totally crazy thing that is
so lost from my control so you feel the
burden of the avatar having to be static
so the the avatar on twitter the avatar
on instagram on these social platforms
uh like is there's a burden it becomes
like because it like people don't
want to accept the changing avatar a
chaotic avatar avatar it's a stupid or
they think that avatar is morally wrong
or they think that avatar and maybe and
maybe it has been and like i like i
question it all the time like i'm like
hey like i
i don't know if everyone's right and i'm
wrong i i don't
know
like but you know a lot of times people
ascribe intentions to things the worst
possible intentions
at this point people think i'm you know
but which is kinds of words yes yes and
it's fine i'm not complaining about it
but i'm just
it's a curiosity
it's a curiosity to me that
we live these double triple quadruple
lives and i have this other life that is
like
more people know my other life than my
real life right which is interesting
probably i mean you too i guess probably
yeah but i have i have the luxury so we
have all different
we don't like i don't know what i'm
doing
there is an avatar and you're mediating
who you are through that avatar i have
the nice luxury
um not the luxury maybe by intention of
not trying really hard to make sure
there's no difference
between the avatar and the private
person
um do you wear a suit all the time
yeah but you do wear a suit not not all
the time like recently because i get
recognized a lot yeah i have to not wear
the suit to hide i'm such an introvert
um social anxiety and all that kind of
stuff so yeah to hide away i loved
wearing a suit because it
makes me feel like i'm taking the moment
seriously like i'm
i don't know it makes me feel like a
weirdo in the best possible way those
suits feel great every time i wear a
suit i'm like i don't know why i'm not
doing this more
in fashion in general you if you
if you're doing it for yourself
i don't know that it's a
it's a really awesome thing but yeah i
think there is definitely a uh
painful way to use social media in an uh
empowering way and i don't know if
anyone has no any of us know which is
which
so we're trying to figure that out some
people i think dojo cat is incredible at
it
incredible like just masterful yeah yeah
i don't know if you like
yeah yeah yeah
so the so so okay so not taking anything
seriously joking absurd humor that kind
of i think doji cat might be like the
greatest
living comedian right now
like i'm more entertained by dojo cat
than
actual comedians
like she's really [ __ ] funny on the
internet
you